ici on est tout près du village de
données c'est une très belle région en
région des cantons-de-l'est sur lequel
je me suis installé depuis juin 2009
pour redémarrer le projet de ferme
maraîchère quels sont les genres des
lacs où jade un lac où c'est ça vient du
créole a ici c'est ce qu'on appelle le
jardin traditionnel
[Musique]
jean-philippe vézina en est à sa
première année comme art et chic
il veut aussi faire connaître à ses
clients des légumes exotiques en les
objectifs que j'avais c'est vraiment de
pouvoir trouver des plants qui avait la
post it et s'adapter au climat québécois
mais qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans les
ingrédients pour préparer des plats de
la gastronomie afro antillaise donc à la
fois afrique de l'ouest les antilles le
sud des états unis dans les produits que
je cultive ici j'ai mangé l'ocrha la
lame à rentrer aux puits l amarante à
feuilles vertes qui se consomme un peu
comme une ennemie pinard qui rentrent
entre autres dans le plat qu'on appelle
de la lho en haïti
pour jean philippe c'est aussi une
manière de retrouver des souvenirs
d'enfance s'était beaucoup une
réappropriation une redécouverte de mes
racines de la culture haïtienne
puis je trouvais ça important que mon
prochain projet la faire interdire ça
aussi dans sa vision qui dans sa mission
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là edem avec
hbo fait lui aussi poussé ses racines
togolaise est envahie 10 ans en
électronique avant il abandonner j'avais
comme on l'a la flamme dans mon métier
j'ai voulu faire quelque chose d'autre
puis c'est ça que m'est venue tout de
suite en tête travailler dans la terre
[Musique]
pour moi c'était évident que par le
coach pas des légumes de chez nous aussi
québec après cinq à six sigma
chaque année j'en rajoute un petit peu
non je fais principalement du jeu du bon
goût ou au crastus le fait de
l'aubergine africaine je fais des
épinards africains de l'osé africains
des piments forts tout comme jean
philippe et dames préparent chaque
semaine des paniers pour ses abonnés
parfois nos deux maraîchers s'entraîne
on fait des légumes qui se ressemblent
un peu mais ya des vérités que moi je
connais pas dumont aussi des légumes
africains que lui aussi connaît -
lancement c'est un partenaire à gauche
chacun va prendre un peu moi je pense
que j'ai beaucoup de nouvelles façons de
préparer des plats les nouveaux produits
aussi qu'on peut introduire aux gens aux
québécois comme aux haïtiens aussi le
chef jérémie jean baptiste originaire de
la martinique s'est joint à nous pour
nous expliquer comment cuisiner ces
légumes reçus ce qu'on a récolté alors
ici on a de l'oseille africaine il ya
deux variétés l'oseille verte houleuse
et rouge
donc c'est sienne elles mêmes
spécificités de que l'oseille connu ici
avec eux ils ne très légère acidité
je vais utiliser l'oseille verte
africaine dans une purée de patates
douces
[Musique]
prochain panier des hawks alors le
bonbon ou le cra a une particularité une
fois cuites et c'est ce qui fait que on
les aime ou on aime pas c est le côté un
petit peu vis q qu'est ce que ça coûte
le crains en fait on est proche de la
sptr jeu ça se prépare aussi comme de la
sptr c'est-à-dire blanchi avec une
petite vinaigrette ou dans une sauce là
aujourd'hui je vais te faire découvrir
l'ocrha dans une salade on va le manger
cru et on va complètement c'est que ces
cartes et parlant du côté un petit peu
cheap et gluant que le bombo peut avoir
après cuisson
et on termine avec une auberge et le
vernis l'aubergine africaine alors toi
c'est drôle parce qu'elle a une forme de
tomates mais elle n'a rien à voir avec
la tomate donc elle se prépare
exactement comme l'aubergine connu qui a
sa couleur violette
celle ci un petit peu plus ferme et on
va la préparer dans une soupe en
accompagnement tu voir cette superbe
[Musique]
part sur un petit bouillon très très
simple ça mouille haut de légumes maison
sur toi de faire revenir des oignons
dans de l'huile puis la juste simplement
verser mon bouillon comme celui-ci donc
on va mettre dans la soute du lait de
coco
donc là j'ai mon potage qui est terminée
bella ici la mare en temps voilà
consommer presque cru puisque on va
simplement les mains c'est hélas rajouté
en garniture dans notre potage aux
locaux un goût de kwh par an c'est dire
et c'est un proche cousin de l'épinard
en termes de goût on va découper notre
aubergines africaine en petits cubes
simplement la faire revenir dans l'huile
d'olive fleur de sel poivre et on
terminera comme garniture sur notre sol
il
au menu salade de tomate et au cra purée
de pommes de terre douces et oseille
soupe d'amarante et aubergines africaine
les plats de jérémy ont ravi les
papilles de jean philippe et de ses
enfants
mais il est déjà temps de penser à la
saison prochaine
c'est ma première saison officielle donc
c'est beaucoup d'apprentissage la plus
grande courbe d'apprentissage c'est
vraiment à accepter le rythme de la
nature te force à prendre mais ça entend
quelque chose que je souhaitais pour moi
mais aussi de pouvoir ralentir clayette
le sang
l'appréciation de ce que la nature a
plus nous donner